and i remember that we were playing
so what one of miles's compositions from
uh the you know late 50s i guess
um and
tony williams tony williams was playing
drums
uh ron carter bass wayne shorter
saxophone
and it was a really hot night the music
was
was tight it was powerful it was
innovative
and fun we were having a lot of fun
and it was the music was on
tony williams was burning on his drums
and um
so right in the middle of miles is solo
when he was playing
one of his amazing solos
and i'm trying you know i'm in there and
i'm playing right in the middle of his
solo
i played the wrong chord a chord
that was it just sounded
completely wrong it sounded like a big
mistake
and i did this and i went like this and
i put my hands around my my
my ears and miles
paused for
a second and then he played some notes
that made my cord right he made it
correct
which astounded me
i was i couldn't believe what i heard he
miles was able to make something that
was wrong
into something that was right with with
the power of his
of the choice of notes that he made and
the feeling that he had
and so i couldn't play for for
for about a minute i couldn't even touch
the piano
you know but uh
[Music]
what i realize now is that
miles didn't hear it as a mistake
he heard it as something that happened
just
an event and so that was part of the
reality
of what was happening at that moment and
he dealt with it
he found something
that since he didn't hear it as a
mistake
he felt it was his responsibility to
find
something that fit and he was able to do
that
that taught me a very big lesson
about not only music
but about life you know we can look for
the world
to be as we would like it to be as
individuals you know make it easy for me
that idea we can look for that
but i think the important thing is that
we grow and the only way we can grow
is to have a mind that's open enough to
be able to accept
situations to be able to to experience
situations as they are
and turn them in to
medicine turn poison into medicine take
whatever situation you have
and make make something constructive
happen with it
that's what i learned from that
situation with miles